there was an article i think it was the
huffington post i'm not sure it said
black men are the white people of black
people yeah
do you ever see that article yeah it's
it's getting to the point where they're
like we need a way to define
privilege privilege so now like the word
white just means like
well in los angeles the other day right
the shooting that took place
uh some blue check dude on twitter
literally went to twitter
a couple hours after and he started
calling the police officer that was
hispanic a white hispanic
right yep that was that was that i'm not
going to say the guy's name i don't want
to give money
i mean that's like inciting race yeah
it's participating literally
and can you believe the people that go
on twitter and start yelling that sean
king is white
it's like come on man oh right come on
it gets clicks it gets clicks it makes
money
um it gives them political fuel for
elections and minorities they just buy
it
you know and i have to say like for the
hispanic community
um 2016 i think the hispanics were
definitely being utilized as political
pawns
i think 2020 right now it's definitely
the black community
for sure well so so do you think trump
is doing well among latinos
and the black i think we talked about
the black community in the polls but
what do you think about the latino
community i think well right now i think
as of 2020 the latino vote will be the
largest vote in american history
um i'd have to look at some structure
that's right right i'd have to look at
some certain polls
but i know that the latino communities
are waking up to the realities and the
lies that they've been told
right like we everybody feels like like
you said earlier right
what won me over with trump was the
human trafficking
yeah was the border situation why
because i didn't want open borders and i
didn't want my country to become like
germany with just complete open borders
and
everything is overrun and overthrown but
as a as a hispanic person
the situation at the border with human
trafficking
there are there are mexican little girls
some that are being human trafficked on
a nightly basis
by coyotes from mexico into the united
states
we got to stop there because people
don't know what coyote means
and i remember when trump referenced
this and they started laughing because
they don't know what a coyote is
yeah so you want to explain what a
coyote coyotes are basically used
they're the runners
they're the hands it's the people it's
the code name the code name the people
that are grabbing these little girls
they go back and forth
some of these little girls are raped up
to sometimes like 45 times in one night
that's such okay and so this is why it's
such a
it's such a shame it's a shame when
aoc or these leftist politicians will
jump up and say
there there's a uh trump there's there's
no national emergency there's no
emergency are you kidding me
are you kidding me there are little
mexican little girls right now as i
speak
that are being raped across the border
that's a problem
and these leftists want to act like they
care about minorities
when donald trump is the one that wants
to do something about it at the border
it all adds up and la and that's what
2016 was about and for me personally
that's what one means take a look at
this article let's take a look
does trump think there are actual
coyotes coming over the border
unbelievable
coyotes no this is this is good this
article is good smuggler coyotes are a
problem at the border not
dogs the fact that vox had to write an
article explaining
this because he trump was being attacked
because trump said he's a nation without
borders as a nation
not at all without borders we have a
reign of chaos crime cartels and believe
it or not coyotes
trump said of the senate spending bill
he's refusing to sign due to it not
meeting his demands on border security
funding
and all of a sudden twitter erupted with
these snooty elitists being like
trump is really concerned about coyotes
like barking and like coming
oh man and so you know you know i did
one time i was like google coyote
and you know trump and i'm like what's
what are you talking about oh the
smugglers that's right
they're making them they're making a
mockery out of human trafficking and
racists
and rapists i got it that's embarrassing
that's a shame that should be condemned
and
see this is this is why a lot of latino
voters are being won over because
the latino community is all about family
and loyalty and when we see stuff like
this
this really pisses us off because it
shows that these people don't care about
our people
i got into it with one of my hispanic
friends because she's very caring she's
very maternal she has a little girl
i was like one thing that you need to
know before you say orange man bad loud
at me and tell me that you can never
consider voting for him
you need to know what is coming over the
border and what is being done to these
people and these girls are your
daughter's age and i didn't i really
didn't want to be emotional with her but
i was like
you know what this is something that you
need to know before you say oh he's too
orange for me he's too bad
and do you know why do you know why
democrats do you know why the left and i
don't i don't want to make it left and
right but this is just where we are
right now
the reason why they won't even talk
about it is because donald trump already
has think about that think about it
the reason why they won't address it
is because donald trump already has
and i'm not up here to advocate for
trump or anything like that i i'm
speaking for these little girls
they won't address it because of their
stupid pride
because they hate donald trump so much
they won't come out and say
maybe we should work with him on this
maybe we should address it too
but they can't because orange man bad
and they hate donald trump so much
that they can't stand up for little
girls 12 year old girls that are being
raped at the border
sometimes 45 times in one night why
won't they do it
not even because of politics but because
of donald trump he's already
done it so they can't be seen aligning
with trump
exactly think about that people think
about that right now
is that right yes or no let us know in
the comments and smash the like button
there you go absolutely there it is
a broken clock is right twice a day to
the democrats
donald trump is always wrong yeah
something's not right there
that means they're they're they're
spinning those dials
how is that possible and i've had people
ask i've talked people about this i've
talked to some people who like announced
they were you know told me they were
going to switch for trump and i said
what was the moment you realized and
they they told me essentially
how is it possible that literally
everything he says is wrong it makes no
sense
and so when all they would ever hear is
he he screwed up he screwed up he
screwed up
then people were saying like people were
telling me like i decided
i got i got to check that because now it
seems weird
because he can't do one thing right now
i'll tell you
i wreck on democrats all the time and i
think they always do things they they
tend to screw up a whole lot
but i've given praise and i try to make
sure if they do something good i'll
i'll give it the respect it deserves
when joe biden condemned violence
he did it he did it a while ago i said
thank you for for calling these people
out and saying they should be
like a month or so ago be prosecuted
thank you however i still don't think
you're fit for president i think you're
weak and your campaign has previously
supported these people
when aoc and warren challenged big tech
i said awesome congratulations thank you
it's the right thing they can't do that
i can say i don't like these people i
don't think they should be representing
us
but i still can respect where they've
done things that i think are appropriate
they won't do that for trump nope trump
can be like these human traffickers are
bad and look like actually we think
they're god they they'll
or they'll shut up when and then they'll
turn around and say
we care about you mexicans we care about
you hispanics we care about you black
people
but when it comes down to it their
foolish pride because of a president
that's
already done it listen it's not even so
much that they hate trump it's because
he's already can you
can you believe so they can't side with
him and we're talking about
human beings we're not talking about
cartons of milk
we're not talking about you know objects
of you know things that are being done
in politics we're talking about people
we're talking about people the most
shocking thing to me
is there has been not one democrat with
the decency
to take a picture of themselves eating a
taco bowl
saying that they love hispanics i'm
kidding
okay it's a little bit of pandering yeah
yeah i know man no they they
they won't and that's insane and that
shows me that they're not being serious
yep because i've long said this and i
think a lot of people have agreed with
me
if the democrats offered up a moderate
candidate who was willing to say
yes to the things they thought were
actually good ideas like
like if trump says we need strong
borders and security and they had a
moderate democrat saying well trump's
right about that
we do need strong security and strong
board us imagine this
imagine very early on in 2016 hillary
clinton was a terrible candidate
like that was the big mistake they made
now they're in trouble if donald trump
came out
in 2015 and was like i'm gonna build a
big beautiful wall 30 feet concrete from
sea to shining sea
everyone's cheering if they had a
regular person being like
you look trump makes a good point about
needing to secure this we do have
problems
and i'm in agreement on border security
i'm not going to put together a 30-foot
beautiful wall from cedar
shining sea i'll defer to him on that
one but i'll put up some new fencing and
select areas
that probably that person probably would
win yeah but they didn't do that they
did hillary
they did warhawk hillary who was talking
about how she didn't care if we ended up
going to war because of the no-fly zone
over
a whole bunch of stuff and she was just
horribly elitist and unlikable
and they lost and instead of giving us
an actual and
from that point on their brains broke
and they could not
ever produce a candidate who was willing
to say oh i agree with trump on these
issues 100
you know we just need this that and this
that's why i disagree they couldn't do
it
if they did probably could have won
instead they get joe biden
i love it when he's like i challenge
donald trump to condemn violence
it's like you know what they're they
they
because they can't agree with trump they
just deny reality yep it's like
trump needs to denounce the violence but
trump's the o he's been screaming about
it for months there's no there's there's
no solution
and you know these people claim they
claim to care
about people from different countries
they claim to care about
mexicans like i'm talking about real
mexicans right from mexico they
they claim to care about latinos from
different south american countries but
they don't i don't think so they don't
you see
like they don't and you see what joe
biden said when he was talking about the
black community
when when like for no reason he
referenced he
he alluded to them being a monolith
essentially when he was like unlike the
latino community
it's like why did you even bring them up
why would you say that yeah they don't
actually care
because if they did they would listen to
the people who fled cuba
like the the what was the name maximo
alvarez was that the rnc
yeah um yeah and that was then you see
that story that was gnarly
the owners of that little shop that
black lives matter was extorting oh and
louisville care about the cubans
you see that story in louisville they
escaped man when i was watching that
that's
uh rnc speech from maximo he his he i
think his family's
he said they fled spain and then uh
cuba and it was like man it was that
speech and andorn speech that were
really
emotionally like heavy i'm
i'm watching all these twitter pundits
who hate trump yeah and they're all
screeching at the top of their lungs
orange man bad making fun of the
speakers
you know what happened as soon as andorn
began speaking their accounts went
silent
it was as though a thousand voices had
been silenced
because they could not criticize a woman
crying over the loss
of first of all it was a white woman who
her
you know the love of her life was a
black man who was gunned down in these
riots because these cities
they could not get a hold of the crime
what are they going to say about that
i'm glad that she was able to speak and
explain you know express the pain she
went through people were crying
you know frank luntz the pollster said
people around him were crying and i'm
like
oh yeah man do you remember the last
state of the union what did nancy pelosi
do
tore up the species she tore up the
speech that included minorities
yeah wartime veterans some people she
hates trump so much
she can't stand these she torp the
of you know included wives that have
lost
husbands there are tons of minorities in
that speech
she stands up there in front of the
world and she rips it
and then they expect us to sit here and
actually believe
that they care about us and i just want
to say this is
you know the hispanic community the
black community
like you guys you guys are worth so much
more than what these people are claiming
you are
you're worth more than a welfare check
you're worth more than
government assistance like you have
god-given capabilities
literally to just take on the world like
you're
you're more than what they're telling
you that what you are
they tell you you need to be on welfare
they tell you you need to be on
government assistance they tell you that
you need uh you know to rely on them for
everything but
you are literally worth and capable of
so much more
so much more as a minority don't let
these people continue to put you in a
box to actually think that
you need a crutch and you need
assistance to live as a human being
that's not progression that's going
backwards that's telling human beings
that you're not worth anything and that
you need us in order to survive
you have the ability to be so much more
you see that viral video where the black
woman is talking about how
trump won without the black vote but he
still keeps trying to
so he got black unemployment really low
and he keeps talking about it how he's
really proud and he's
trying to help people out and she's
saying he didn't do that he didn't do
that he won without the black
the black vote why is he still trying to
you know help the community
and she's like i like it so she so i i
think
i think trump maybe because they aren't
maybe because the other side has had
decades to change things for these
communities and they have not chicago
hasn't gotten any better
all these blue cities it's gotten worse
listen
for people listening right now the black
community
had the first the first black
president of the united states and where
was he from
chicago and has chicago technically
hawaii but right but has chicago gotten
any better
even after the advent of the first black
president of the united states of
america
no why there's actually a lot of people
in chicago who
who brought that up particularly in the
black community they were like
you know obama was here what did he do
and
i i will be fair and say some of these
cities have have
you know deep-seated problems that are
not so easy to fix
but i will tell you at a certain point
whether or not with the
like look los angeles has a democrat
super majority
they can't solve their homeless crisis
it's almost like there's no political
competition so what happens is
a democrat runs they either win by
default or they just say yeah look we'll
give you all these things there you go
and then they get elected and they just
don't do anything but no one cares no
one votes for anybody else
i think one of the problems is that
republicans don't try
to gain a foothold in many of these
areas and because there's no competition
the democrats do nothing they're they're
a dull blade
because it's the only thing you get it
is a monopoly the democrats in many of
these cities is akin to a cable service
provider that has no obligation to
service you properly
because what are you going to do about
it i'll tell you this you ever see the
south park episode where they go to the
uh the cable company and the guy has the
flaps on his nipples
and he's like he's like yeah tell me
about your problems and he's like yeah
he's rubbing his nipples
democrats like oh yeah exactly that's
democrats in these cities exactly
being like oh oh you have a problem who
are you going to vote for oh that's too
bad you can't vote for anybody else
yep there you go you know and i still
like
i still have to and i know i'm going to
get a lot of crap for this but i still
have to speak to these communities
because they're still
voting that way they're they they still
vote
for that but i'll tell you accept it but
i'll tell you what the problem is in my
opinion
donald trump has been trying really hard
to uh
to particularly to get the black vote
yeah but i think i believe he's actually
trying to help the black community yes
and if you look at kanye west and
candace owens and many of these black
conservatives
why they support trump i hear them and
i'm like wow
i i hear what you're saying it's
interesting i respect your opinion
congrats you know do your thing
i think it's going to take outreach
donald trump did it
yeah donald trump was like vote for me
let me work for you
but i was talk we we had a black
conservative billy prempe
who was running in north jersey for
congress and he's basically saying how
they don't the gop doesn't want to even
bother with many of these these
deep blue cities because it's too
expensive so they focus elsewhere
you have to you need political
competition
at least try it's it's yes and
and even if trying is like even if you
can't win
you are chipping away at this you know
to to form that sculpture over time
you need to go around do outreach look
in aoc's district
the republican who was running against
her when she first ran didn't even have
a website yeah i don't know
i i'm assuming that's true if the fact
factor because i was years ago now
but like not even really running see but
but here's i think this is where the
conversation tim turns into more
is do i love you because i just met you
bro
listen though if i love you i'm gonna
run into a burning building for you
even if i know i'm going to die risking
my life to save you i'm not going to
calculate i'm not going to say oh well
you know the odds of me making out of
this alive
are either this this they're this i'm
going to do everything i can
in that moment to get in there and to
save your life
and i think politicians don't have that
heart for these communities
definitely not and i think that's what a
lot of people
are starting to realize and i think this
is where the conversation turns into
love for america love for human beings
because listen
the gop needs to understand this who
cares if you waste
five million dollars in a district who
cares if you waste all that money on
these communities
but if your answer to me is it's just
it's just not worth it it's not worth it
it's too much money
it's not going to work out i don't think
we can make that happen that shows me
that you're not willing to run into the
burning building and save lives because
you don't love these people
or just statistics to you even on the
right yeah i think that's why a lot of
republicans are retiring
yeah for the longest time people just
and i do love you tim
yes and we have the cat who's he's mad
he wakes up around 10
and he's like he's awake yeah cause he's
like the show's supposed to be over feed
me
yes i think about we're seeing we're
seeing a lot of new republicans start
running
they're like energetic populist
republicans and i think this is the
shift we needed where people are finally
waking up
you had democrats republicans alike who
did not care for their communities
they just knew they get reelected and i
think they liked it they liked it there
were areas that would always be read in
areas that would always be blue because
it meant their job was secure
well now it's being challenged and now
they're starting to get angry a bunch of
republicans are like i'm retiring donald
trump
actively trying to help people in
politics
i think there's a there's some light
there's a light at the end at the end of
this tunnel here
well everything seems dark and we've got
anti-fun all this chaos it could just be
that we're getting the toxins out you
know
you know we're flushing those toxins out
toilet's gonna stick for a little bit
but i'll tell you what you'll feel
better in a week or two
a better way to put it is whenever i was
little and i felt like i was gonna throw
up my dad would always say
just go throw up and you will feel
better it's you're sitting here
complaining that you're on the verge of
throwing up for 10 minutes just
go barf and it'll be over with that's
what we're seeing right now
we need to barf up all these incumbents
and bring in real politicians that
actually care about the communities
that's why i'm really impressed with
people like kimberly klasik and billy
prempe
they're they're in areas that are blue
but they're like
we have to stand up for what you believe
in yeah black conservatives
it's not about your race it's about
whether or not you care about your
community
and i think they're running in places
where the politicians don't and they do
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you